et je pense que jeany mohamed a raison
pourquoi il a dit on est en guerre mais
en guerre on convoque l'armée pourquoi
on fait pas des hôpitaux partout avec
l'armée qui vaccinent tout le monde
mais qu'est ce qu'on fout parce qu'on a
besoin de ça mais avant les boeufs et
qu'on nous confine pas c'est parce qu'on
n'a pas les vaccins c'est parce qu'on a
rien à nous donner en échange il a parlé
des médecins cet après midi il a réuni à
analyser tous les irakiens qui ont
fabriqué ces vaccins way et tous ceux
qui n'ont pas développer de molécule
mais qui sont prêts à le fabriquer aux
comptes les autres labos le président a
dit une chose c'est long très long mais
est d'accord objectif c'est quoi ces cas
des vaccins pour chaque français est
l'objectif il l'a rappelé un vaccin pour
chaque français d'ici l'été
mounir hambaoui mounir on va le tenir
cet engagement
mais hama pour tous les français on va
le tenir à une condition mais c'est une
cause ou celles à laon l'ensemble parce
que c'est que non c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui rendra les français les personnes
immunisées mais pour ça avant l'été pour
c'est l'objectif canon ces prisons de la
république et pour ça on fait comment eh
bien on demande à des jeux tous les
laboratoires y compris les labos
français qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui de
françois hollande qu'il a mangé chez les
mangeurs clafoutis chine à faire quelque
chose pour vous c'est la déprime est
qu'on va produire dans les usines qui
sont pas les usines des laboratoires
étrangers les les vaccins de ses
laboratoires là ça ça veut dire quoi
seul français qui avaient la possibilité
de fabriquer il est obligé d'aller aux
états unis s'est cru à ce que vous lui
avez pas répondu aux micros dans les
ministères et notamment au ministère de
la santé on peut refaire des précédents
quelques mois mais là on n'est pas
certain
on attendait c'est de la politique
franchement vous avez parlé du globish
ces macro qui a nommé le comité
scientifique si c'est pas pour l'écouter
derrière qu'est ce qui va se passer on
espère que les restaurants ils vont
ouvrir au mois d'avril au mois de mai à
ce rythme là ils vont ouvrir en
septembre mais ses pensées du jour rien
n'est prévu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui un danger en urgence mais
qu'est ce que monsieur mounir qu'est ce
que vous allez faire monsieur lajoie
je suis à jouer je vais laisser parler
un spécialiste mais juste un truc
comment vous allez faire dans quinze
jours quand on sera à 6000 personnes en
réanimation
qu'est-ce que vous dirais ok il ya une
campagne politique qui arrive on sait
qu'on a un an des présidentielles
mais là ils jouent à la roulette russe
vous rigolez ou quoi on est en train de
jouer avec la vie des français bien
évidemment ça fait chier mais c'est vrai
mais ça fait chier tout le monde sait
confinement mais on est tous d'accord
cc c'est terrible pour tout le monde
mais à un moment donné il faut que ce
soit le plus court possible
quel est votre solution saas alors on
aurait dû effectivement tripler les
places en réanimation et devrait y en
avoir quinze mille et non pas encore
5000 aujourd'hui mais là ce que vous
regardez c'est qu'on est à 3002
aujourd'hui c'est 62 % des lits de
réanimation
vous allez faire quoi dans dix jours
puisqu'on sait qu'il ya un décalage de
quatre semaines quand vous allez vous
retrouver et qu'elle 5000 places en réa
qui seront mal il s'est laissé leur
répondre mais qui répond aujourd'hui je
comprends votre inquiétude c'est sûr que
se dire que on avait tout le monde chez
lui ça va immédiatement avoir un effet
c'est certain mais c'est aussi
énormément de conséquences et donc quand
vous dites on va forcément le faire plus
tard mais aujourd'hui rien ne nous
indique que le pic à va arriver dans
deux semaines ou dans trois semaines au
contraire nous nous montre que le pic
n'est pas en train d'aller payer au
mécénat l'exemple de ses dessins guti
dernier quinze jours aux gambiens et
fournit un an d'une campagne
présidentielle